three and two now to conform with the
bases empty and one out
[Applause]
and he threw him a curve and he drills
it into right field for a basin and
that'll go back to the wall
and conforto as harper bobbles it off
the wall pulls in at second base with a
double
he's not very good here he took the
words out of my mouth thank you
that was stumbling
no no it's a team team game
keith
assist put out
one two coming
and the breaking ball hits the center
field hazely giving ground hainsley
turned around can't get it
that'll bring in conforto smith pulls
into second base with an rbi double and
the mets lead it one to nothing but i've
just seen some really poor outfield play
this year
i mean that's a f8 on your score card
that's just
misplayed so the mets with three hits in
this opening inning a pair of doubles
they played a run
that snaps nola's scoreless inning
streak at 11. he's not trying to trick
anybody right now
[Applause]
pitch the nap and nap hits it in the air
to left field
fairly deep going back on it is mcneal
it is gone
andrew knapp goes the opposite way his
first home run of the year he continues
his hot stretch to begin the season
and the phillies have tied it up at one
he did not get it up in the zone as you
typically did and he jumped all over
center cut fastball really good looking
swing on it
and he is so hot you know how difficult
it is to come off the bench and not play
as much as little as he's played and to
swing the bat like that
nola with a left leg kick deals to pete
peter lonzo drives one to deep left
field and the mets are back in front off
the facing of the second deck
alonso first pitch he sees from aaron
nola
his ninth home run of the year and the
mets are back in front two to one oh
right down the pike
right down broadway a little above the
belt but that's a ball that pete's been
swinging through or fouling back
and that's much more of a level swing
[Applause]
and he's so doggone strong and that's a
nice swing there's nothing wrong with
that swing
that's now one for six with runners in
scoring position and it's left to andres
jimenez
who struck out his first time up
he bats with the bases loaded and two
out he gave him a lot of curveballs
and he lines one up the meadow base hit
in comes dom right behind him is canoe
mcneal heading for third he makes it
safely andres jimenez drives in a pair
and it's 4-1 new york
amena is getting more and more playing
time and making it pay
and he continues to shine
[Applause]
he started three straight games and in
those three games he's five for eight
with four runs batted in
well done
so the mets able to take advantage after
the phillies gave them an extra out
and canoe wraps one down hoskins it gets
on by him here comes conforto around
third segura's throw to the plate is
wide as conforto scores and the mets
laid it
5-1
remember canoe hit a hot shot on friday
night late in the game that hoskins
caught this one
he didn't
that could be you could give him an
error here
[Music]
i think that's an error
we'll see how they score it
if it's ruled an air boy the defense has
really let this philly team down even if
it's a base hit
it's a play you should have it's a it's
a long hop
so
nola has had poor support today in 912
career ops which is great
that's drilled to right field by mcneil
toward the wall and it's out of here
jim mcneil with his first home run of
the season
in at bat number 116
jeff mcneal finally gets one over the
wall
curveball down and in not much break
that's where jeff likes it
and we've seen him do that
so that's right into his wheelhouse
in his life nemo cracks one to deep
right center harper goes back takes a
look and that's out of here
brandon nemo adds a home on his sixth of
the year and it's 7-1 new york
[Applause]
third home run of the day for new york
alonso mcneil and now nimmo
this ball's crushed
[Applause]
beltai
that yet set to run 3-2 coming to walker
and he struck him out
an even dozen for jacob degrom finishing
off his day's work
one run three hits 12 strikeouts over
seven that'll play degrom had 35 swings
and misses today which is not only a new
career high for him
it's the most of any pitcher in any
major league game in the last four years
the last picture to have as many as 35
swings and misses in the game was danny
duffy with the royals in 2016.
luis guiorme on deck 1-2 to dom and he
rips one to right field for a base hit
in to score comes
nimo the ball gets by harper
conforto scores
it's a two-run double for dom smith and
the mets now of a 9-1 lead in the eighth
inning a four hit three rbi game for dom
smith
flicks one down the left field line
mccutcheon over near the side wall and
he turns away from him and he stands
fair and it bounces out of play for a
ground rule double and that'll bring in
two runs that ball appeared to be going
foul and somehow it came back into fair
territory
eluded mccutchen
and the phillies nightmare afternoon
continues that's now lead 11-1 they need
to go home get some rest
i don't think the phillies could play
any more more poorly and now alonso
unloads one toward the left-field corner
and this ball is out of here
second home run of the day for pete
alonso this was a two-run shot and the
mets put the icing on the cake it's now
13-1
the tenth home run for alonso his second
of the day
and the mets have themselves a
party against the phillies this
afternoon well here's ramos who's
already struck out four times today
first time in his career he's had a
golden sombrero
he would like to avoid platinum and he
does by flying one deep to right harford
looking up at the wall and it's out of
here
wilson ramos adds to the carnage the
mets fifth home run of the day and it's
14-1
that's put up seven runs here in the
sixth inning their biggest inning of the
season fastball up and he got the barrel
on it
2-2 to boom and he struck him out and
that'll do it for the afternoon the mets
with a laugher
as they set season highs for runs and
hits they hit five home runs including
two for pete alonso as jacob degrom
strikes out a dozen
in seven innings and the mets beat the
phillies for the second straight day
14-1